so the last few frantic days of this
election campaign are underway
candidates are exhausted campaigners and
knocking on as many doors in as many
marginal constituencies as possible and
maybe irritating you like madam so they
bit irritated with my doorbell keeps
ringing but my next guess who put their
fair share of hours campaigning into
many campaigns over the years I've
decided to hang up their boots so they
can now with those shackles removed give
us an insight into the final few days of
this election former Conservative MP for
Wantage had Phase II and former Labour
MP for Ashfield Gloria dear Piero
good to see you this morning quick word
about the debate last night because it
is the sort of hot topic if you like
flat do you think all safe I think they
sort of appeal to their respective core
votes I'm not sure it was a big
game-changer Jeremy did very well on the
NHS Boris got some a hit on the attack
on terrorism so I don't think was a game
- the other thing I wonder is it was on
Friday night and if you are like vaguely
normal wouldn't you'd be like I think so
I don't the rate I'd be quite
interesting seeing the ratings to be
honest because some poor black you were
well I enjoyed every minute of it
because obviously I was out I didn't see
it so for me is the absolute perfect
I've been the real debate that's quite I
gather that Boris won at 52 48 which is
of so dividing like it in British
politics when you decide you're not
standing at the next election that you
do just AUD mop happy you don't do mop
happy but what I do I do feel very
strongly well that sounds a bit odd it
doesn't it feels wrong about this but
anyway I feel detached in a way I can
kind of look at politics I think in the
way that a lot of voters are looking at
politics you know when you're in the
Westminster bubble particularly when
you're campaigning every nuance every
rau every stray semicolon in a tweet
becomes this massive bun fight in
Westminster but actually if you're going
about your life in a relatively normal
way you pick up to a certain extent the
same amount of politics as 99 percent of
the public but you're doing a lot of
door knocking still in my informal
constituency so I haven't quite hung
boats up yet and it's quite tough I mean
not just because of the cold what and
what response are you getting on but on
the door
this um there are too many doors and if
I'm absolutely honest with you I don't
know if they really are don't knows or
if they don't want to tell me that's
they're not sticking with the Labour
Party so it's a really important last
few days for the Labour Party well I
don't think we've been doing enough of
is outlining what another five years of
Tory government will look like and I
think the next four four or five days it
has to be absolutely focused on painting
that picture of another five years and
asking can you not forward another five
years of this when people don't surely
people can turn around say can we afford
five years of Jeremy Corbyn government
look at these spending plans a huge this
is this in a sense not necessarily the
spending plans but what I'm feeling too
much on the doors because it feels like
it's a referendum on the Labour Party
and whether or not it sees fit to govern
rather than a proper choice because you
know can you try to get a GP appointment
lately because you know I haven't it's
taken me 18 days
that was my first offer you know we all
know about school cuts we all know about
those difficult things and I mean I
should hate and say I'm doing a bit a
bit of talking oh god I want to give the
impression that I've just sitting on my
sofa and but mainly in the southeast so
I'm not seeing as it were what might be
happening in the red wall and to a
certain extent the election campaign
feels relatively normal you knock on a
door
people either say yep we're with you or
they say go away in different ways
obviously in the south breaks it does
play a role you there are voters out
there who are not gonna vote
conservative because of brexit this is
their chance to have a protest vote
that's reflected in some of the seats
I'm campaigning but I think one of the
things I have picked up is that I do
think to kind of pick up on what Gloria
said about a referendum I do think the
big decision I think the public is
making up its mind about is whether they
can face another hung parliament and I
suspect that the decision is they don't
want another hung parliament and then I
think if they're going to decide whether
we're gonna have a government led by
Boris or Jeremy Corbyn I suspect and
obviously I'm still partisan I'm still a
Tory but I suspect their decision is
going to be Boris Johnson that's
that's my gut instinct and that is
certainly a feeling that when people
talk about getting brexit done they
don't mean get breaks are done they mean
let's have a majority government but you
know you know on this bricks get brexit
done thing I mean because of course I
broke the whip so did a 19 other Labour
MPs to vote for the second reading so we
were on the path a path to get brexit
done so it's a little bit of a myth it's
a very strong sound bites it has been
repeated you know with great focus and
but actually for the first time we've
pasts yes that's not my point I don't
think the public are saying if we vote
conservative we get breaks it done I
mean no but I think they are saying if
we've we want to vote in a majority
government that will get something done
the last two and a half years their
impression quite understandably and you
can go into the ins and outs of why is
that nothing got done and people want
something done is it damaging that we've
got to former Prime Minister's Tony
Blair on the other side so John Major on
your side who are both basically saying
don't vote for the parties that I led
how damaging Ray's would be suboptimal
but it's obviously damaging but again it
goes to this point about what is cutting
through in this election so I'm on the
outside looking in to a certain extent
I'm not waking up thinking I can't
believe John Major just asked people not
to vote conservative specifically in
three seats
nor have I got embroiled in whether or
not it's now a constitute part of our
Constitution every prime ministerial
candidate should be interviewed by
Andrew Neil I don't think that stuff is
necessarily cutting through it's
obviously astonishing for Westminster
Watchers he's voting labour you know and
you know I do think this country needs a
change of course
so still love him because he gave us you
know three electoral victories but I
don't think she'd have done that I mean
it's interesting one of our last guest
was so Nicky Morgan I think was just
saying that you know Boris Johnson did
address last night the the John major
issue Jeremy Corbyn can't bear to say is
no he's not been a fan of of Tony Blair
for
a year that's no surprise but but that
level of shifting the party so far away
from from what successfully Tony Blair
did isn't that part of the reason that
there is some concern listen I've been
in Parliament for nine years I was
elected in 2010 it has been so sad and
distressing to me that all of those
years in Parliament have been in
opposition where I can only say no and
never say yes so of course the reason
why the Labour Party exists is to change
people's lives and you only do that from
being in government so to be honest at
the last election and it's been coming
for a while this disconnection with
working-class voters there needs to be
an absolute and it should have come
before now focus and an investigation
and listening exercise some of it will
be brutal but it has to happen because
we're not just talking about CC we're
talking about the seats that are our
soul you know an interesting point and
go because you you know you're out of
the game now we can be brutally honest
I mean realistic I'm really scared that
it counts the next four days is
absolutely crucial but I am worried at
the state and can the Conservatives
definitely hold on to the lead that
they've got me it's tempted ten points
ish as I say I think I think my gut my
gut is that Boris will come back with a
working majority I've called every
election wrong since 2005 so you don't
need to say what I say with a huge pinch
of salt because I say my gut instinct is
that the public are so fed up with
having a hung parliament they will vote
for anyone who will give them a
government and they're not getting into
the details I mean I know that there's
been all this exchange of you know will
its manifesto deliver X Y Zed again I
don't think that's cutting through I
don't think anyone particularly wants
this election I don't think they're
enjoying this election but if we're
going to have an election I think the
public is saying we'll use this
opportunity to return a majority go well
can I just say talking to you to know
that you're not going to be elected next
week very good to see you both thank you
thank you